humph gum res - paper welcome to the
final episode of second son infamous
this is gonna be a good one
friends family [ __ ] this one is for
you
goodbye that's been great how [ __ ]
dare you tire touch me
Moses don't let anyone touch him I
[ __ ] up I don't want to want to fight
me in my life thanks girlfriend
[Music]
alright I'll keep climbing then how I do
not know need your along for the ride
you can my two favorite people in the
world in the knock-down drag-out alright
whatever you say lady oh wow thanks
Rufus
ah hey lads ow so impolite so goddamn
[ __ ] impolite snow says join my clan
can't believe you haven't heard of it
yet
Hey he gave up before amazing what now
this is someone left mate nice wall they
thought they work where you go now wait
a yo that's weird
aren't you supposed to do something now
all right well I'll keep climbing then
not what's she doing
ah thanks Carol you're the best
why does she go though hmm that does not
look safe I [ __ ] it what are you gonna
do ah yeah
there we go
it's gonna be fine here it better be a
fight
I'm fine we fighting a little bad guys
thank you girl
appreciate it what are we going then not
there uh suppose my god are you Craig
Craig she is cray-cray oh no oh you got
a little worried there for a second did
yet oh god they're shooting me [ __ ]
[Music]
mates don't start the party until I
arrived real fast
oh that's what I'm talking about dude
shut the [ __ ] hey where is it I didn't
see why she put it I'm still looking for
it oh there it is thank you go here we
are
[ __ ] there's two helicopters Eugene yeah
dorky as ever
oh I don't even have to do anything
there's awesome sorry could you go back
with him the [ __ ] he came from that'd be
great thanks thanks good for ya
yeah he maybe I should climb this thing
yeah just about to say the same don't
call me D please you don't you don't
want to be trust me
Wow Wow
Jesus randomized junk she wants the D I
knew wait I've seen all day
Wow finally realizes city [ __ ] down and
join the samosas flying the matrix
come to me matrix I am the matrix armor
plate
[Music]
the current [ __ ] don't rush meat D you
like being rush
alright let's use it [ __ ] it hopefully
works on helicopters I don't know I
don't really Oh what is this do holy
[ __ ] what am i doing all throb real fast
what I've been watching you Delsin Rowe
testing you while you assembled your
little bag of tricks
very impressive yeah I know all about
what you did to using Hague to set up
that crash making Eugene and fetch look
like monsters just so you could look
like the hero someone has to protect the
conduits protect in the seven years
since my DUP took over conduit oversight
for the military not a single one of our
kind has been killed
oh nine you just kind of bad and lock
them up yes in curtain K protected from
the mobs that want to kill conduits it's
what's best for them whether they know
it or not that's both shadows make that
decision for huh yeah some decisions are
too important
I've seen how people look at you in the
street do you know how rare it is for
the powerless to embrace a conduit
you've got to use that popularity that
trust to convince them that the only
solution to the bio terrorist Menace is
my DUP I'll do it after I rip your
[ __ ] spine now that over half the
conduits who died in the bloodbath seven
years ago were killed by the military if
they regain control what makes you think
things won't return to those good old
days goddamn it do you care my brother
okay no I'm gonna expose you maybe
already picked anyway in your deception
and then we'll see who the real
protector is
that would be a death sentence for all
conduits can't thank you that starfox
oh it's alright
and [ __ ] hate her so much
I guess its power of television going on
here we shall predict it more really
didn't
there we go here's a moment yes see go
down no [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] it up come on [ __ ]
there we go kick her in the nuts why the
hell did she go
yes just your ass
no there's no mercy never get here
[ __ ] boohoo story
seven years ago my unit was there to
save lives from a new threat conduits
people with powers that no one
understood they had the power to kill
Helen conduits and the power to
transform some of us into conduits to
I found another survivor she tailed me
as I made my way back to the safety of
my battalion together we traveled
through a lawless city that wanted us
dead because of what we now are everyday
people join the lynch mob horrified by
the thought of conduits hiding among
them we'd hurt no one but they could
only see us as monsters
when military order finally asserted
itself they treated us as the threat
I was conduit I was military
but I couldn't be boss so I made another
option it was oh wait no in that first
conduit alive I'd earned the
government's trust and that was just a
start they funded the creation of the
DUP thinking we were just freaks hunting
down other freaks but that wasn't it
I was going to say as many conduits as I
could
if my kind were going to live it would
be behind the walls of curtains kay
bullish a seven years I've kept them
safe for me I won't let anyone do that
government not the army yeah
not you seven years old you've done
just keep them locked up what would you
do
just throw open the gates that couldn't
a station I'm more free but your ass I
would the world isn't changed in the
past seven years inside the conduits
they relax you turn them out that I'll
be dead inside a week so tell me who's
the Saviour and who's the most oh [ __ ]
oh my what the [ __ ] it's that a stark
stone golem snake of death of God damn
it Thanks
the filter the mousse
oh [ __ ] waiting
can he fight for me fine
oh [ __ ] sorry I miss give me one second
darling get me hip power more
constipation I knew it okay I'd gladly
have that power before Boulder - hey
girl
see Miss
oh that's it I just won five I mean I've
been Sonic all this time I mean small
it's Manik and samosas so don't try and
teach me this [ __ ] now I thank God
[Music]
Go Go suck it up give me something good
come on something I can damage her with
what is this constipation okay I can
deal with that got it
is that damaged her day this
how that much that good enough there we
go nice and smooth for us
nice Oh God she's a snake she's a snake
if that golden from poking in up [ __ ]
oh my god oh never mind how do i
recharge my powers though gave me that
date yeah yeah yeah squeeze it out on
there guys now I can fly fantastic
didn't need that at all hopefully that
refills my golem thing though
yep
what oh god I was so good I wish I could
use this to recharge oh cool I can fly
like a baby look at this this is stop
that's awesome Oh
Rainy's fast really fast get it grates
out that gyrus what do we get oh that's
our cinder blasts hell yes this is gonna
be awesome okay okay okay I run nice
pass
okay get out get out get out you know oh
god what is this Oh God
how'd its my concrete refill I don't
even know how oh oh that was so close
that is get out get out get out get out
get out get out get out get out get out
can i yes oh that was so close oh my god
that was okay
Oh God we're so close for us come on
ah no no no now setec for the love of
God if you ever sent it ever in your
laughs the nails the time all of a
sudden come on so [ __ ] fast oh my god
you're so fair Oh Oh dog
oh it's my turn to play now yeah
I'm told that hurts Slade you can see of
Augustine where her eyes peering out
from that concrete shell the rage that
had filled the moments earlier was now
replaced by fear we dismantled the
fortress she had built the army she had
raised the future she had planned the
entire world to know that she had failed
taken down by a gamer a junkie and a
small-town Zelinka
the crowds cheered as Augustine was
hauled away before all this no one would
have imagined that humans and conduits
could coexist and now I was the guy
kicking off the second age when those
conduits who'd spent years locked inside
the walls of curtain K they were soon to
be free once again to live their own
lives to choose their own futures
it's for me I got what I came for
now and now now I had a promise to keep
oh you're here
I miss Reggie it's common God promise is
a promise right huh and the others I
just got here you're my first stop you
saved me water comas we take care of our
own right
where's Ritchie oh god don't Reggie had
you see
[Music]
flexy got a diamond yeah it supposed to
we did in the very beginning
we did it finished it hell yeah yeah
they it was a great [ __ ] game I
really really like that like a oh [ __ ]
like I said it was the first game I play
on next-gen and it it was cool like it
just just the graphics just the graphics
was enough note but it's seriously like
amazing graphics runs so smooth you have
this open world with this awesome power
so you can just use and fun characters
and believable characters like Reggie
and I don't know I just really fell for
it and it's just an overall nice package
of a game I don't know what else to say
really I just I just really enjoyed it I
thought it was very nice and I think you
bros like the - so that's all it was
very cool it's very cool to share these
experiences with you bros it's playing
through a game is very awesome
I gotta miss this game like I never
really cared much for the infamous IP
but this really blew me away like it I
didn't think it would be this good
to be honest people weren't kidding when
they were praising it because the game
was receiving a lot of praises and you
know obviously now we know why because
it is a great game
I hope from what I'm I'm honestly like
looking forward for next infamous game
now which is cool I guess you could say
I'm a fan of the series now because it
was really awesome
I wonder if Dalton will be in it then I
don't think so
I feel like his story is 12 it's still
ah it's feel sad to kind of leave leave
the story or in the characters I know
that's kind of silly but I don't know I
feel like I'm never gonna see these
people again and that's sad I can't be
the only one to think like this I don't
know that's just me I guess very cool
style to like all the art art art were
key sequences and that stuff it's cool
to see Seattle - I feel like I would
love to go there and visit now in a
weird way I don't know I'll I'll go and
I go there and climb the tower or some
[ __ ]
Eugene I don't know much about Eugene
but they nailed Dalton and Reggie that's
for sure
even becky and really cared much for it
to be honest especially for family
supporting we needed ring that's sweet
high five Oh a final high five high five
ohh feels alright breast that's it for
me like it's so much for watching the
series you're an ultra bro for it
thank you for livin alike and here's the
final brofist for this series stay
awesome bros i know you will refused